We're going to make all this little hand
wavy stuff that I did, which I like,
a bit more concrete,
which you should appreciate because
I'm making abstraction more concrete.
>> Thank you, thank you very much,
I'm here all week.
In order to do that,
we're going to actually introduce
a real formalism called options.
And options are just a way of writing
down explicitly what we mean by this
temporal abstraction new actions idea.
>> Okay, and is this related to concepts
like the financial version of options?
Like stock options?
>> I'm going to say no because I've
never really understood those things.
>> So maybe they are related.
>> Probably not though, I'm going to say
that options are just a fancy way of
saying choices is a fancy
way of saying actions.
Here's what an option actually is.
So an option is a tuple because
everything in life is a tuple and
it has three parts to it.
So in fact it's a triple,
it has I which is the initiation set,
it has pi which is almost
always the case a policy, and
then it has beta which
is a termination set.
So let me explain what
I mean by those things.
So the initiation set I is just the set
of states where the particular option or
super action, like go to doorway in the
south, is actually legal to be executed.
So this is where it may start or
initiate.
So there's a set of states where
an action actually makes sense.
So let's take your action, which was
go to the the door to the south, right?
So that's clearly legal
inside the northeast corner,
but I think the way you meant it anyway,
it's not really something that you would
execute from, say, the southwest corner.
That seem reasonable?
>> Yeah, I feel like it sort of violates
the spirit a little bit if it's the case
that you can navigate to that
south doorway from anywhere.
Then why not just navigate to
the goal from anywhere, right.
We're not really breaking it
down into simpler subproblems.
Right exactly, so
in fact we should just have one
action which is solve the problem.
>> Right.
>> And you should just execute that.
That's going to be at least as hard
to learn as the original problem and
probably as hard to execute.
If you already had that then there
was nothing to do in the first place.
>> Is the aesthetic here sort of like,
I don't know,
algorithm design in computer science?
The sort of idea that you want to break
a problem up into subproblems but
somehow have solved a little bit of
the main problem along the way in
thinking of things like Quicksort and
Mergesort and so forth where you
recursively solve the same kind of
problem, but it's not cyclical.
It's not like you make no progress
because at each time you break down
the problem it actually makes
it a little bit easier.
>> Right, so in fact I think the word
abstraction here is quite important,
we do abstraction when we code,
right, we create functions.
And then we use those functions to
think about the problem at a more
abstract level and it allows us
to solve the problem more easily.
So it's yes,
I think that's a pretty good analogy,
it's not a perfect analogy, there's not
really an input and an output here.
But it's trying to solve
the same idea of modularity and
re-usability for that matter.
>> And it allows us to make
the problem easier to think about and
easier to solve.
>> Cool.
I like how computer science comes up
even inside of computer science.
>> Yes, computing is everywhere
it is computing all the way down.